now India's top Court has ruled that a
disputed religious site be given to
Hindus for the construction of a temple
the piece of land in the state of Uttar
Pradesh is claimed by both Hindus and
Muslims now in its ruling the Supreme
Court said Muslims should be given two
hectares of land for a mosque at a
different location India's government
will set up a trust to manage the site
and oversee the building of the Hindu
temple now dispute over it just who owns
the land has been one of India's most
contentious issues Hindu hardliners
destroyed a 16th century mosque there in
1992 sparking riots that killed at least
2,000 people the court added the right
to build a temple on the land will be
subject to peace harmony law and order
well the disputed land is located at
high Odia in the state of Uttar Pradesh
which Hindus regard as the birthplace of
Lord Rama and Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi has just addressed the
nation he called the ruling a golden
chapter in the history of the Indian
judicial system he also said that people
from all religions and communities have
accepted the decision wholeheartedly
now Mohan Bhagwat is the chief of
India's RSS that's a right-wing
organization which is considered the
ideological parent of the ruling BJP he
hopes action on the site will soon begin
we're confident that the government will
soon take the initiative to resolve the
dispute in accordance with the decision
of the supreme court we should forget
past issues and all of us should come
together and fulfill our duty to build a
grand temple where lord ram was born
well a lawyer for a Muslim group in the
dispute says they will examine the
verdict in very close detail we are not
satisfied with the judgement we have you
then we will decide what future course
of action will be ours that is detailed
detailed records cannot be made just now
but you can say that the judgment and
there are some incorrect findings also
so we will examine them but virtually
chiseler Supreme could be respected
there is no question of and the VIII
appeal to the nation to observe
restraint and peace
while our correspondent Rivera joins us
now live from the capital New Delhi and
surely as we've just been hearing there
there do appear to be some inherent
contradictions in this ruling now Modi's
saying that everyone has accepted it
wholeheartedly how true is that well I'm
not very certain out true that is
because we've been talking to people and
we've just you've displayed the
soundbite of the lawyer who says that
they are not they accept the verdict
which they see some inherent
contradictions there so but the Prime
Minister the fact that they need Prime
Minister saying that this is a new dawn
that this is a golden chapter and also
interestingly enough comparing it to the
fall of the Berlin Wall that's sort of
an event here but it's a positive thing
that he's saying is I think what he's
trying to say is that Hindus and Muslims
will from now on be united and worked
together for the development of the
entire country but it's hard to see how
that's going to play out because Muslims
in the country especially under the
current government do feel marginalized
they do not feel empowered they don't
think they can stand up and say things
that they perhaps could earlier they've
always been a minority and in that sense
marginalize but even more so now so
there's a bit of a gray area as to what
exactly is Prime Minister Modi doing
here it's a positive message
but is it true on the ground because
there are some voices that we beginning
to hear offer the members of the Muslim
community who not very happy with it
some people on the streets we spoke to
who said they would have preferred the
verdict of the High Court a lower court
and the Supreme Court which was given in
2010 which even though gave two thirds
of the land disputed land to the Hindus
and one-third to the Muslims at least
gave them something but now it's sort of
pushed them out that seems to be the
feeling at least among the people we
speaking to and until we saw all that
violence and those two thousand deaths
back in 1992
so I imagine very tight security across
the country today well that is correct
mostly the security arrangements have
been put in place in utter Pradesh which
is where I odious and I oh yeah is a
small town which is where the disputed
land is so 12,000
policemen and women were deployed there
they said that they've also had
thousands of meeting with local Hindu
and Muslim leaders about making sure
that there is no violence and you know
peace prevails everyone is really
tight-lipped no one is sort of emerging
and saying anything that could provoke
anyone there have been celebrations but
not massive celebrations they have not
been any sort of vocal protests as well
so people are being very careful because
everyone understands the other situation
can get out of hand
so even if the Muslims perhaps wanted to
protest they're not going to do it
because everyone is sort of taking a
step back and saying look there are this
could get out of hand and we've got to
sort of all be really really cautious
but massive security arrangements have
been put in place the government is not
in a mood to take any chances and so far
there with that update from New Delhi
thank you on shell well for more on this
we can speak to sanjay Hege who is a
lawyer at the Supreme Court of India and
he joins us now on skype also from New
Delhi mr. Headley let me start by asking
you about this seeming contradiction and
what the courts decided so by my
understanding the previous attempts to
convert the site into a temple they were
ruled as illegal but now it's determined
that the site will become a temple so
what's the legal basis for that the
legal basis is simply this it says that
both sides have proved the case to a
certain extent and therefore decreased
for possession should follow but since
the the deity is to be given possession
of the land and a temple would a would
be coming up there it the Muslim side
should not feel in any way alienated and
therefore Court has ordered using its
special powers under Article 142 that an
alternative site of Annie could make if
equal if not more magnitude which is
suitable for that purpose we offered to
the Muslims that the way that both
things should happen simultaneously
basically the court has tried to do a
balancing act without necessarily giving
in to
which were strictly on the basis of pure
civil law but Mr Hague do I understand
the court was essentially looking into a
claim over land ownership right so what
then is the basis for the court to
decide what should be built on the site
rather than just saying who owns the
land well you're right and normally
there there is what's called the law of
limitation on that land existed a
structure which was a mosque the
installation of idols in the mosque in
1949 the court says was wrong the court
says the demolition of the a of the
mosque was illegal however when it
finally comes to the question of
restoration of the site back to the
original owners the court prefers to
molder relief in a different way and
that it does using its special powers
and article 142 of India's Constitution
which permits the Supreme Court to do
complete justice in any matter let me be
slightly more realistic about the court
judgment the court seems to have
basically taken into account majority
majority sentiment in India say which
would possibly render any order which
for reconstruction of the mosque at that
very site physical if not a social
impossibility so it has instead
preferred to close the chapter give a
lot separate pieces of land and then
hopes that the country moves on but some
may feel that the chapter isn't closed
so is there now further legal recourse
here for Muslim groups if they decide
that they don't actually agree with this
ruling well I'm sorry
legally speaking they can file a review
petition but a review petition often
goes to the same bench though the Chief
Justice will have written by the time
that a review petition comes up so there
will be one
one more addition but a bench of five
judges is unlikely to review to
substantially change the final decision
in a review yeah there is technically a
remedy but I don't see it going very far
in terms of effectiveness Sanjay had
either a lawyer at India Supreme Court's
thank you very much for joining us and
your insights on al Jazeera